they gave me credit for communicating i
understood the questions without
difficulty i answered i express myself
without difficulty but with mistakes hi
there steve kaufman here
is it important to speak a language
perfectly is it important to make
essentially no mistakes or to try to
make no mistakes
to try to sound like a native speaker
i think if you've been following my
videos you know that i don't think it is
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
the reason i want to talk about this is
because my wife and i watched the
final of the french open tennis
tournament
a few days ago
and it kind of reminded me of how
important it is to focus on
communication rather than these
what i would call almost futile pursuit
of perfection at least futile for most
people
and so the reason i'm talking about it
is because
novak djokovic who's an amazing tennis
player just a delight to watch
and who's also a
a real gentleman
as are all of those top tennis players
roger federer um rafael nadal
so much respect so much respect
for their opponents
um
you know it's it's it's a quality that
that it seems very often in
in some circles uh has gotten gone out
of style you know win at all cost trash
talk your opponent uh
this kind of thing and it's i find that
so distressing you can compete but after
the competition is over then you should
respect your opponent and of course
that's what rafa
rafa of course and and joko do
and so the other thing that they both do
and and as does serena williams
is if they're in front of a french
audience they will respect their
audience by speaking french now of
course you have to be able to speak
french and understand french in order to
answer questions and communicate in
french to
thousands of people in the audience and
potentially millions of people around
the world
and so i was so impressed with joko
and i've heard him speak um
english obviously he's flawless in
english
i've heard him speak italian i presume
he speaks spanish i'm sure he speaks
russian but his french
is wonderful it's natural it's pleasant
the the fans at roland garros were
delighted to hear him in french i was
delighted to hear my friend i was almost
proud of him good for you
and but he doesn't speak without
mistakes
he doesn't he has what i guess is a
serbian accent
in his french
he made mistakes with his gender gender
you know he he said things like for
example instead of mafami he was
thanking his family he was he decided to
thank month family doesn't exist there's
no there's no family and it's in any
case
doesn't matter however if if there were
a french teacher there if his french
teachers from school were gonna you know
give him marks for his uh
talk there she'd probably mark him down
and i know that like in canada where in
the federal
bureaucracy they hand out you know
bonuses for being
bilingual
if someone were to say mon family in
their test they would be marked down
they probably wouldn't get their
bilingual bonus
and but yet other people will not make
that mistake but they can't get up in
front of thousands of people and
naturally and and comfortably speak in a
way that
they look comfortable the audience is
comfortable
communication is taking place so how
many of the students who got very high
marks in french say in the canadian
school system in the english-speaking
school system
are capable of getting up in front of an
audience like joko did and speaking
french
and so
communication is so important of course
joko would like to speak better and
apparently in a previous uh interview
he said that you know he's working on
his french and he wants to acquire more
words which is the right thing to do by
the way work on getting more words a lot
of the grammar will fall into place uh
occasionally review the verbs
i'd love to have joko on link
i think he'd really improve but the
point is he would like to improve but
wherever he is whatever his
level is he's not uncomfortable using it
now obviously you have to be at a
minimum level you can't be up there and
not understand the question and this was
when i was in ukraine for example in
kiev and i was interviewed in both
russian and ukrainian on television
i could understand the questions i
answered and some people pointed out
that i made mistakes sure i made
mistakes but i think the fact that i
spoke in both russian and ukrainian to a
television audience first of all there
was the audience in the studio and also
people watching on television
they gave me credit for communicating i
understood the questions without
difficulty i answered i expressed myself
without difficulty but with mistakes
and so i think this is important we've
had this discussion about pitch accent
and all this other stuff and people can
spend their time doing that but i think
the bigger thing is
to to focus on communicating as i've
said before just about everybody that i
have dealt with in english and i have
dealt with non-native speakers in
english in my business career be they
swedes germans
uh japanese you know french chinese
spanish
most of them speak with an accent
most of them speak with mistakes and yet
they communicate very comfortably
everybody feels comfortable they feel
comfortable because
we have the impression i as a native
speaker that the person i'm speaking to
understands
perfectly what i'm saying and i
understand perfectly what they're saying
even if they make the odd mistake so
we obviously we all want to improve
uh and we have to get to a certain level
before we can you know be comfortable
and before people listening to us can be
comfortable but once we're at that level
then i think we have to focus on
communicating
rather than
again it's not a matter of you shouldn't
but those who communicate
at a less than perfect level should be
given credit for what they can do should
give themselves credit for what they can
do even if they are motivated to
continue working on getting better so i
just wanted to give kudos to joko and i
should add in i've seen rafa do this
roger federer of course is magnificent
in so many languages i've heard serena
speak very good friends serena williams
um
so and and we should also recognize
that english speakers we say wow you
know so-and-so spoke french and if we
have like i know that uh
whatever that english tennis player i
can't remember scottish tennis probably
spoke spanish very well
but these non-english speaking athletes
and politicians and others they're
always speaking english and they're
speaking english well albeit with
mistakes and i'm always impressed even
when it comes to speaking english i'm
impressed when i hear people hockey
players you name it america like
baseball players in the u.s from the
dominican republic or somewhere and they
all speak english so well
more english speakers should make the
effort
to speak those languages and get up in
front of an audience like joko did like
serena has done and so forth and so on
so i'm full of admiration for those
people even though they speak less than
perfectly
and i'll leave a couple of videos that
kind of
follow the same subject
bye for now